hello in this video we'll talk about the
process of cellular locomotion cellular
locomotion is a result from the
coordination of motions generated by
different parts of the cell
cell locomotion underlies various
physiological processes like neutrophil
extraversation wound healing and the
cell migration even that takes place in
the embryonic brain
so let's understand the process of cell
migration in bit more details
so the property which is exhibited by a
moving cell is the polarity that means
the anterior part of the cell is very
different from the rear part
so in the anterior part of the cell
the the movement is initiated by
formation of a large broad membrane
protrusion known as the lamellae podium
and there are
finger like projections coming out from
the anterior part of the cells and these
are known as phyllopodium
both these structures are really
important in cellular locomotion if we
zoom inside these structures we can find
branched actin structures in the
lamellipodium and the actin bundles
present in the phylopodium
so overall it tells us that actin
microfilament network is really
important for cellular locomotion
now let's look at the cell from the side
view and try to understand what happens
when the cell tries to move
in fast moving cells such as fish
epidermal cells movement begins with the
extension of
one or more lamellipodium
and if we zoom in
in the anterior part of the cell we can
see actin networks are now growing and
kind of pushing the cells
forward
so
there are certain molecules such as
prophylene and cofilin regulates these
actin dynamics in the anterior part
profiling severed the actin filament
and increase the solubilization of actin
whereas prophylene helps in
polymerization of the actin
now both these movements are really
important during cell migration
lamellipodium and phylopodium creates a
stable contact with the underlying
surface and it is preventing the
membrane from retracting
now there are focal adhesions between
the surface and several attachment in
the cells
now let's zoom into the anterior part
and try to look at the leading edge of
the cell in the leading edge of the cell
there would be detachment
of the membrane
and this membrane would move a little
bit ahead and form a new adhesion
likewise the cell
body that means the portion that harbors
the nucleus and cytoplasm would
eventually push itself forward
and now if we focus on the posterior
part of the cell it would now detach
and thereby the cell moves one step
forward
this set of movements are repeated
while a cell is migrating in this
animation you can see how the cells are
migrating by repeated repeating this
particular set of movements
now let's try to understand what are the
factors that govern these kind of
cellular
so there are set of
monomeric g proteins such as rac rho
cdc42 all are related to ras
and these set of proteins are known to
be crucial for cellular movement
mutations associated with these gdps
lead to severe defect in cell migration
there are classical experiments which
helps us to understand how these
movement can re can be orchestrated by
several
components
scientists have found that
adding fgf or fibroblast growth factor
lead to formation of
membrane ruffles which are actually
protrusions upward protrusions of the
membrane
now when rack which is discussed earlier
which is a gtpas is micro injected
into the fibroblast immediately almost
immediately
membrane ruffle forms
it takes some time
for the focal adhesion and the stress
fiber to form
so that tells us there are two sets of
events which are temporarily
differentiated might be regulated by
different factors
later on scientists found that if they
add inactivated rack then the effect of
fgf is abolished
here we put fgf in the media at the same
time inactivated rack is injected
into the fibroblast and this leads to no
membrane ruffling activity
point to be noted at this point all the
focal adhesions are very intact
now when rho was micro injected in the
fibroblast
focal adhesions and stress fibers
were
forming that means rho is somehow
involved in the later part of this
cellular movement
similar effects has been reported when
lpa is injected into the cells that
means they can work in a common pathway
all these set of experiments allows the
scientists to construct a pathway
of how these cell movement can be
regulated so there are set of
extracellular factors such as growth
factors tropic factors which leads to
cellular movement binds to cell membrane
receptors on the cell that is undergoing
movement
and
these
factors ultimately lead to the
production or activation of this
monomeric g protein g protein such as
cdc42 rack or rho each of these g
protein has their own activity for
example cdc42 is involved in phylopodia
formation whereas rack
interacts with the actin network and
thereby regulating lamellipodia
formation and membrane ruffle formation
whereas rho interacts with myosin and
helps in the formation of stress fibers
and the focal adhesion
also
crucial experiments has shown that
these gtpases also work in a
hierarchical fashion such as cdc42
regulates rack and rack can regulate row
and thereby
overall this network can regulate how
the cell locomotion can take place
and thereby we are understand what are
the overall
cellular and molecular players involved
the cell locomotion process
so in summary we looked at the stages of
um cell locomotion and we took fish
keratinocyte as one example of a fast
moving cell
and we also looked at the signaling
factors and regulators that
are involved in cell locomotion if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you